(man) the sharks are back.
They're looking for the best
products and Businesses
America has to offer.
And tonight, guest shark
LORI Greiner joins the tank.
I can tell instantly
if it's a hero or a zero.
Hopeful entrepreneurs
come to the shark tank
seeking an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
What sales do you have?
We've hit over $5 million.
(sharks) whoa!
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest...
I have an offer for you.
Using their own money...
it's called taking a chance.
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I don't want to
do business with Kevin.
Doesn't matter what you want.
It's not your business.
(chanting)
Shark fight. Shark fight.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
Are you willing
to go closer?
No.
It's sink or Swim.
Come to daddy.
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Lori Greiner is
the queen of qvc.
She holds 108 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing $500 million
in Worldwide retail Sales.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
First into the shark tank
are Kevin and Melissa Kiernan,
who believe
they have a solution
to a problem
faced by millions of Americans.
♪♪♪
My name is
Kevin Kiernan...
and I'm Melissa Kiernan.
And we're from
waldwick, new jersey.
Every morning,
I come outside,
and there's garbage
all over the place.
So I finally put my husband,
who's Mr. Fix-it, to the test,
and told him that he needs
to solve this great mystery.
So my daughter and I
took it upon ourselves
to investigate
What was going on.
We got all geared up.
We would sit there and wait
and wait and wait,
and then we found out
the culprit--
raccoons.
And now I needed
to come up with a solution.
So we went down to
the local home hardware store
and we designed our product,
and we got
a tremendous reaction.
We're seeking an investment
from the sharks
for their resources
and their retail connections.
And also to be able to
have this put on every shelf
in the United States of America,
in every store.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Kevin Kiernan...
and I'm Melissa Kiernan.
And our product
is called the last lid.
We're seeking
a $40,000 investment
for a 20% stake
in our product.
Every day, my wife and I,
we are faced with the nightmare
of having to clean up
our own trash,
and the root
of the problem is,
is that we just don't have
any garbage can lids.
They all seem to disappear.
We don't know where they go.
Maybe the garbage man
throws them away.
Maybe the wind
blows the lid down the road
and it blows it away.
It's really disgusting and we've
been dealing with this for years
so finally I became fed up
and I said, "listen, Buddy.
"You better come up
with a solution
or find another place
to sleep."
And you know the old saying.
"A happy wife
equals a happy life."
I figured all I had to do
was go down to the local
home improvement store
and buy myself
a replacement garbage can lid.
But guess what?
To my surprise,
when I got down there,
that just was not an option.
No.
Stop the madness.
You see, the store--they want
you to buy just the garbage can,
and I only needed the lid.
So now I had to get
into macgyver mode here
and I had to
create something,
and that's why I created
the last lid!
(laughs)
Now the last lid
is a fabric replacement
for your garbage can cover.
It's made of 100%
water-resistant
polyester material, it fits
on most-size garbage cans,
and it's very simple to use.
You're gonna attach
the handles on both sides.
I've added a velcro strap
on the one side
for added strength
and security,
and then there's
a metal clasp,
which is the key
to the whole element,
that connects to the handle
on the back side.
So now guess what?
Now you never have to worry
about losing
your garbage can lid again.
And that's why I can honestly
stand here and tell you today
that this lid right here
will be the last garbage can lid
you'll ever gonna have to buy,
and that's we're calling it...
(both) the last lid!
So what's to stop a raccoon
from just peeling it right off
or gnawing right through it?
Let me just tell you--
little background for you.
I've actually videotaped
my competition.
Just like on your team,
you play the next team
the following week,
you watch a videotape, right?
Here I go.
I set up a camera in
my 8-year-old Daughter's window.
We look. We make adjustments.
I've changed materials,
I've changed fabric,
I've changed designs...
so what are you saying?
A raccoon can't rip that off?
A raccoon cannot rip that off.
Nah, come on.
Raccoons get
very easily deterred.
They try to get it, they can't
get it off in a couple seconds,
they move on
to the neighbor's bin.
I know it's sounds Crazy.
Swear to God.
Always--always deterred.
Let's pretend
you're a garbage man.
Yes.
Right.
You take it off.
Here you go.
Done.
That's it. Done.
Okay, so what's--
what sales do you have?
At this time
we don't have any sales.
We've actually pretty much
finished our prototype.
We have a patent pending.
And so you haven't sold any of
'em and you're trying to offer
the value of this
is $200,000 company.
That's what your numbers
are saying.
We actually feel--
and don't laugh--
we actually feel that
that's an undervalue...
(sharks laugh)
Because the bottom line--How'd
you like that? Is that good?
(Robert) That's Good.
That's good, right?
If I do a search for
replacement garbage can lids,
what am I gonna find?
You can buy a normal
garbage can lid online...
but guess what?
For certain cans only.
This is a universal fit.
This will fit
on pretty much
90% of all the garbage cans
that are out there right now.
There's not a universal
garbage can lid?
No way.
There are none,
is what you're telling me?
No. No.
You know, the irony of it all
is that you're gonna have to do
what I did if you really wanted
to solve this problem.
All right? And that's
ultimately--I stared at it,
I looked at it, I said,
"what am I missing here?"
and then it hit me,
daymond--fabric.
Why not make a fabric
replacement garbage can?
It's universal,
it stretches,
it works--
but, Kevin,
that's an awful idea.
Then you got to clean it.
You got to wa--
That's the best part!
Rain--if it rains,
it gets wet, it gets soaked.
Yeah, what happens
when it rains?
Robert, this is
machine-washable.
I want to take something
that was on my garbage outside
into the house and clean it?
Well, you can hose it off
with a hose outside as well.
I have no interest
in this product.
Come on, Robert.
I think it's a bad idea.
Come on.
Don't bail out yet.
Listen, w-we haven't
even talked about--
licensing--
licensing This.
Look, let's go to Mr. Cuban
over here for a minute.
Congratulations on your victory,
by the way.
Wouldn't it be great to see
your team logo on this?
How many fans do you have?
On a piece of garbage, Kevin!
It's not a piece of garbage!
Yes, you want
your logo on garbage.
Come on! How do you not
see that's a bad idea?
Robert!
But I can't believe
you're gonna bail out.
You were
a stay-at-home Dad.
What's that
got to do with it?
Because I know
you've dealt with this!
I'm out.
Aw.
Lori, I know
one thing about you.
I watch you on qvc
all the time,
and I know you don't
take "No" For an answer.
You have
a can-do attitude.
So come on.
This is a great product.
You have
a can-do attitude!
(Lori) I love your passion--
Lori, come on!
I-I love your passion--
Lori. Come on!
It's a great product.
This is
a great product, Lori.
You have
a can-do attitude!
One shark is out.
Kevin and Melissa
are really hoping
that they can
get Lori on board.
You have
a can-do attitude.
So come on.
This is a great product.
Here you go--busted.
(Lori) I love your passion--
Lori, come on!
I-I love your passion...
Lori. Come on!
It's a great product.
I understand, I relate to you,
I know what it was like,
but I can tell instantly if it's
a hero or a zero, and I'm sorry.
Really?
Come on, Lori.
I think this is a zero.
I'm out.
Ohh, Lori.
Hold on. We haven't even
talked about the market.
There's over 200 million
garbage cans sold
in the United States alone,
with 115 million households--
we already know--
look, it's a given there's
garbage cans everywhere, right?
(Melissa and Kevin) Right.
What you haven't gotten into
as you've prototyped this
is what it costs to build, what
you think you can sell it for.
Okay, let's talk about that.
Right. I mean, basically, our
production cost on this thing--
cost Per Unit's gonna be
about $3.50 a Unit.
How much you gonna sell for?
So you figure $19.95 for 2.
I don't like the numbers
right now.
7 bucks to make it. You want to
sell it at $19.95 at home depot.
They need a margin on that,
so they're gonna buy it
from you at 10 bucks.
All right? That's $3
for me as the investor and you.
Right.
That's not enough.
I'm out.
Three sharks are out.
Mark and daymond
are Kevin and Melissa's
last chance for a deal.
I have some of
the same issues as Kevin--
the fact that
there's not enough margin.
You don't have enough
room to invest...
right.
To take it out into retail.
Unlike Lori and Robert,
I think it's a good product,
but you're gonna have to build
this business on a slow build
as opposed to a rapid build.
Sure.
Okay.
I just don't think
it's ready to be accelerated
and--and blown up into
something really big quickly,
because of the lack of margins,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Daymond, come on.
(daymond) yeah?
If I may? Listen, seriously,
this--this is a huge issue.
We've come up with
Some staggering numbers
where at least 60% of people
don't even have
a garbage can lid period.
Well, the numbers are staggering
in various ways.
$200,000 for the concept
of the company
is a staggering number.
The fact that
you have zero sales
is Another staggering Number.
What if I was to raise
the--the equity in the company?
I'll give you one shot.
Give me a number
and make it good.
It's on you, baby.
It's all you, baby.
We'll do the $40,000.
Let's say we came in at...
60% of our company to you.
That's better than you expected
and you know it.
Wow.
I'm in.
Whoo!
Congratulations.
Yeah!
We got the man!
Daymond! Thank you very much.
Pleasure to meet you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, sharks.
Congrats, guys.
(Robert) Congratulations.
Thank you, sharks.
Thank you.
Daymond, I can't believe
you did a deal
for a fabric cover
for garbage.
You know why?
Why?
Because I was trying
to find a top for my garbage
about a month ago,
and I could not find it.
I could have sold you one
for a lot less than $40,000.
(Kevin and Lori laugh)
We thought we were done,
we thought we were finished,
and then my old man daymond
came through for us
from queens, New York.
We love you, daymond.
You're a hometown boy.
Thank you, daymond.
In season 1,
for their product lightfilm,
a decal that lights up.
I'm in. All right.
Wonderful.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
Right after the show,
we got together with daymond,
put together
a marketing strategy.
We went from lightfilm
to powerdecal.
Now powerdecal is a cordless
product that you can change
from one lens to the other
throughout the year.
It never quits.
Today is such a big day.
Powerdecal is
on the shelves of best buy.
Daymond was instrumental
in getting our product
placed at best Buy.
Doesn't get bigger than that.
We were able to go secure
all the major league
sports licenses--
nfl, nba,
major league baseball, nhl.
Not only that, but we have
250 different colleges.
We did it.
You got it.
All right.
Thanks.
I would say in the next
two quarters We're probably
gonna be doing at least
$5 or $6 million in gross sales.
I mean, we couldn't have
done it without "Shark tank."
This is the American dream,
this is what "Shark tank"
is about,
and it doesn't get
any better than this.
♪♪♪
Next into the shark tank
is Amanda schlechter,
who's looking for some big help
for her small business.
♪♪♪
My name is Amanda schlechter
and I invented the ledge Pillow.
I'm asking for $30,000 for
a 25% interest in my company.
My beautiful model Martina
will hand them out
so you can take a look
at 'em up close.
Thank you, Martina.
The ledge Pillow is
a fully patented
WEDGE-type Pillow,
specifically for women
with Breast implants
or just large breasts, to lay
on their stomach comfortably.
(sharks chuckle)
it is the only wedge-type Pillow
on the market
for women with Implants
or with Large breasts
to just lay on their stomach.
I had an AUGMENTATION myself
and I couldn't sleep
on my stomach anymore.
So I went
to the fabric store,
borrowed my mother's
electric turkey-carving knife,
and began to carve out
the design
that you see patented here.
Who knew we had
this big problem?
It's a problem.
Thank goodness.
I knew this was one
that the guys would want
to get their hands on.
How many women
have this problem?
How many women would you say
have breast implants?
Well, there are
5 to 10 million women worldwide
that have breast implants.
What? Really?
That many.
What about
naturally large breasts?
Absolutely.
This--this--
what size increment
do we have to get to
before the wedge Pillow
becomes a factor?
"C" Cup and above, uh, really
would need the ledge Pillow.
And how high can you go
in the alphabet?
Well, to be honest with you,
I think bra Sizes go up
to sort of double-k.
In--in the U.S.--
Wow.
What?
Amanda, would this work
on a double-k?
Yes. The idea is to minimize
compaction here. It's not just--
I'm trying to
visualize a double-k.
I bet you are.
Okay. Ignore these guys.
No, no, this is important.
(Lori) Have you sold
any of these?
Oh, yeah.
Absolutely, absolutely.
How many?
I've only sold 83 of them.
83?
Yes, 83 of them.
I only had a WEB site up,
uh, since 2008...
(Lori) 2008.
So it hasn't been
very long, and--
since 2008?
3 years? You've been selling
for 3 years and you sold 83?
I have absolutely no money
for advertising, so--
no kidding.
(sharks laugh)
It could be
a fabulous product,
but if you can't
let people know about it...
let me ask you something.
Women with Big boobs--
do they sleep on their stomach?
Sure.
Or do they--do they,
over a course of time,
realize that hurts,
and they sleep on their backs?
Well, they sleep
on their backs now
if they don't have
a ledge Pillow.
Well, because most of the guys
up here are married.
I happen not to be,
so I've had the pleasure of...
being with more than one woman
in the last 50 years.
And how much
did that cost you?
(laughter)
Uh, way less than
it's costing you guys, trust me.
And usually they sleep
on their back or their side.
That's because
they don't have a ledge Pillow.
(Kevin) Okay, but daymond--
now why wouldn't they just
put a regular small Pillow
underneath them?
Because it doesn't
stay in place
and it doesn't have
the--the appropriate foam
to keep, uh, you know,
sort of the uplift.
Okay, so you've had
the patent granted? Correct?
Correct, Yes.
Which is great.
So you've got an asset there.
My concern is,
it's been three years.
Well, to be completely honest,
I am a single working mom,
and, uh, I have not had
the time or the money
to devote to the ledge Pillow
that I had hoped.
I appreciate your ingenuity.
There was a problem.
You were trying to find
a solution...
Exactly.
Which is great.
I, personally,
when I look for a product,
some of the most important
elements for me are
broad appeal
to the mass markets,
selling to
the largest audience that I can,
and I think that your product
is just too niche for me.
Well, I will tell you,
the average bra size--and I was
actually shocked by This--
is a 36dd in the U.S.
(Lori) Wow.
So that would be--
so it's just--
isn't this the essence
of your problem?
You start with a product
that only 50% of the population
will buy anyway--Women.
Then you say women with
Large breasts--smaller Subset.
Augmentations--even Smaller.
Then it get worse, Amanda,
much worse--
Only women that want
to sleep on their stomachs.
Now we're down
to a universe of 83,
and you've met 100%
of the market with your sales.
It's over.
Why don't you tell her
what you really think?
You know what?
You're so nasty,
and at the end of the day,
you and I are very similar.
We'd make very good partners.
But it's a nightmare,
as you found out.
You have lived a nightmare
since you brought this out.
You've sold 83 Units.
This product is not going to
make anybody here any money.
And Lori can be very nice to you
and say that in a different way.
At least with me
you get the truth.
It's a dog. Stop wasting
your time with this. I'm out.
I'll give you some advice.
What I think you should do first
is change the name
to something that has "Boob,"
"Breast," something in it,
but because it doesn't have
a broad mass appeal,
I'm--I'm out.
Amanda, you're not
dealing with the facts.
In 3 years, selling 83
is such a small amount.
Women would have found you
if there was a demand for it.
I'm out.
You guys are my last hope.
I don't know
how to market to this area,
and you don't either...
unfortunately.
It's not my Area.
That's why I'm standing here.
I respect that,
but I-I can't add any value
to you, so I'm out.
You're not an entrepreneur yet,
Amanda. You're a wantrepreneur.
You want this
to be a company,
but you don't want it bad
enough, and that's the problem.
You just tell me
what to do, and--
that sounds Good.
It's the truth.
It's--it's the truth.
But it's not.
It's not,
and I'll tell you why.
You're not gonna be a person
where if I write you a check
for $30,000,
I can trust
that you're gonna go out there
and just bust your Butt.
You have to do what you have
to do to be successful,
and I don't see you doing that,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Well, thank you for your time.
Everything's
a learning experience,
so I will respectfully take your
comments, so I do appreciate it.
You can stay.
(sharks laugh)
(Robert) Yeah, you were right,
mark. Not the dedication.
Just a product.
Just a bad product.
I don't think
it's a bad product.
It's just that the market
that needs it is too small.
(Kevin) 83.
♪♪♪
I'm Steve nakisher...
and I'm Shane Talbott.
We're from chicago, illinois.
Steve and I have been together
for the last 15 years,
and for the last ten
we have been business partners.
So what are we
gonna do today?
I'm a hair colorist,
and my experience in that world
has really taught me
how to pamper people.
As a psychologist, I find it's
so important to teach my clients
to relax, to take a moment
to take care of themselves...
and we realized that
this was our opportunity
to put our passions together,
and our product is amazing,
because it really adds that
touch of elegance and luxury
to Somebody's day.
And it gives people
an opportunity
to slow down
and take a break.
If we don't get a deal
from the sharks,
it would be like
the death of a dream,
and I hate
to see that happen.
I've put so much of my heart
and passion into this,
I hate to see that go.
♪♪♪
I'm Steve nakisher,
and this is Shane Talbott.
Our company is called
Talbott teas.
We are seeking $250,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in our company.
Talbott teas
is a cup of Couture--
designer whole leaf teas
and accessories
that are steeped in style.
They are chic, elegant,
and glamorous.
We are reinventing
the tea experience
the way Ben & JERRY'S
REINVENTED ICE CREAM.
AS A TEA COUTURIER, I WEAVE
TOGETHER INDULGENT INGREDIENTS
TO CREATE
AN INDULGENT TEA EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE 23 DESIGNER TEA BLENDS
THAT WILL WRAP YOU
IN AN AROMA, BEAUTY, AND FLAVOR
THAT IS PURE INDULGENCE.
I MEAN, NEXT TO WATER,
TEA IS THE MOST CONSUMED
BEVERAGE IN THE WORLD.
THE TEA CATEGORY IS FAST-GROWING
YET UNINSPIRED.
TALBOTT TEAS IS
AN AFFORDABLE DAILY INDULGENCE.
WE'VE BROUGHT SOME TODAY
FOR YOU TO EXPERIENCE.
FOR YOU, WE HAVE
GREEN TEA HEAVEN.
THANK YOU.
LORI, FOR YOU WE HAVE
BLISSFUL BLUEBERRY.
MR. WONDERFUL?
YES, THAT'S ME.
CHOCOLATE ALMOND ALLURE.
AH, MAIS OUI.
YES.
WHY DOES IT SMELL SO GOOD?
DAYMOND.
WE HAVE ORANGE CREME DREAMS.
THANK YOU.
AND MARK--
COCOA CARDAMOM SEDUCTION.
THAT WORKS.
(Robert) WHAT ARE YOUR SALES
TODAY, SHANE?
IN 2009,
WE HAD $100,000 IN SALES.
IN 2010,
WE HAD $350,000 IN SALES.
OH.
(Kevin)
WHAT ABOUT THIS YEAR?
BETWEEN PURCHASE ORDERS
AND WHAT WE SOLD,
WE'RE AT $500,000,
AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN HIT OUR BUSY
SEASON, WHICH IS FOURTH QUARTER.
WHAT IS SPIKING YOU
LIKE THAT, THOUGH?
2010, WE HAD
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
WE WERE ONE
OF OPRAH'S FAVORITE THINGS.
AH.
AH, THERE YOU GO.
THE OPRAH OPPORTUNITY
WAS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
WE HAD THIS FANTASTIC SPIKE
IN SALES, AND THEN AFTER,
WHAT WE WERE
KIND OF SURPRISED BY
IS THAT'S WHEN THE OPPORTUNITIES
STARTED COMING.
SO ALL OF A SUDDEN, WE HAD
ALL THESE DEPARTMENT STORES
AND GOURMET GROCERY STORES...
SO THE RETAILERS--
THE DISTRIBUTORS
STARTED CALLING.
AND THE RETAILERS.
THAT LED TO OUR FIRST
QVC APPEARANCE.
DID YOU SEE LORI THERE?
I DIDN'T SEE HER THERE
AT THE TIME,
BUT I CERTAINLY KNEW
SHE WAS THERE.
(Kevin) HOW DID THAT GO?
IT WAS A SUCCESS.
WE WERE JUST INVITED BACK
AND THEY ADDED FIVE NEW ITEMS.
SO THE FIRST PURCHASE ORDER
WAS FOR $20,000
AND THE SECOND PURCHASE ORDER
WAS FOR $200,000.
WOW.
SO YOU GUYS ARE KICKING ASS.
I MEAN, YOU'RE KICKING ASS
AND TAKING NAMES, RIGHT?
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE WE NEED HELP
TO, UH, CAPITALIZE OUR GROWTH.
WE ARE ON
A GROWTH TRAJECTORY
AND WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS OURSELVES,
BUT WE DON'T JUST
NEED THE MONEY.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
TO HELP WITH THE DISTRIBUTION.
GUYS, TALK TO ME ABOUT
YOUR MARGINS A LITTLE BIT.
ON $500,000 IN SALES
SO FAR THIS YEAR,
HOW MUCH PROFIT
HAVE YOU MADE ON THAT?
WE'RE CURRENTLY
AT A 50% PROFIT MARGIN
AND WE DON'T EVEN BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE HIT SCALE.
BEFORE YOU PAY YOURSELVES,
RIGHT?
CORRECT.
HOW MUCH IS IT?
MOST OF THE TINS THAT YOU SEE,
UH, WITH 30 SERVINGS IN EACH,
RANGE ANYWHERE
FROM $10 UP TO $15, RETAIL.
IS THAT THE PREMIUM SIDE
OF THE TEA CATEGORY
IF I LOOKED AT OTHER PRICING?
THAT IS THE HIGHER END.
YES.
HAVE YOU TESTED YOUR PRICE POINT
TO RAISE IT UP EVEN HIGHER?
WE HAVE NOT YET.
ACTUALLY, IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT WE GO UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER ABOUT,
IT'S ABOUT THE PRICE POINT.
YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE HIGHER?
I TEND TO BE SOMEBODY
WHO LIKES LUXURY...
YOU WANT IT HIGHER...
(Robert) I HEAR YOU.
AND HE'S THE BUSINESS GUY.
PERFECT.
THIS IS LIKE
THE DOLCE & gabbana of tea guys.
How much money
have you raised,
and is it your own money or do
you have external partners?
We've invested $300,000 of
our own money in the Business.
Wow. So you guys--
you--you believe.
We are in.
We do believe.
Just the 2 of you,
and you're 50/50 partners?
Yes.
So what do you do
when you disagree?
We've worked out a system.
What's the system?
I win.
Shane is always right.
(all laugh)
He's all creative,
I don't step on his toes,
and I do the business side,
and he doesn't step on my toes.
Shane, what's the big plan?
Tell me the next five years.
If I give you $250,000,
what's the plan?
The Big plan is,
this is just the beginning
of a lifestyle brand.
I would really like to see
more of the accessories,
some tabletop, there could be
some licensing down the road.
What's the exit strategy?
How do I get my money back?
It will be a liquidity event.
We will sell this company
for four or five times earnings.
You do know
what you're talking about.
We agree that we can grow this
to $100 million in--in revenue.
I think this is an incredible
story, but unfortunately,
I'm already in that space
as an investor,
and so I'm conflicted out.
I wish that I was doing the deal
with you instead,
'cause I'm losing my shirt
in the other space.
You would not
lose your shirt with us.
I-I know, but I can't, 'cause--
due to conflict, so I'm sorry.
Regretfully, I have to be out.
Guys, I'm a big fan
of what you're doing, too,
but I live, eat,
and sleep my businesses,
and I couldn't eat,
sleep, and breathe tea.
So I wish you the best--
I think you can be
a $100 million business--
but I'm out.
Daymond, you said
something that concerns me,
'cause I'm thinking
of their story.
You mentioned that you'd made
an investment in a tea company
and lost your shirt.
What happened?
I think the guy running it
is a bozo.
These guys--
and I-I didn't know
enough about it
to get into it,
and I'm trying
to off-load it now.
I think this is a great space.
That's why I got in it.
You know, caffeine is the number
one drug in the world,
and they're selling it.
Well, what I like
about this story is,
although the Category's
not growing,
it's also recession-proof.
People that drink tea,
drink tea.
True.
Tell you
what I'm gonna do.
Um, I like the story,
I like what you guys are doing,
but I don't like the value.
You know, it's one
of those not-easy deals,
which always troubles me,
'cause viscerally I love
to just say "Buy it."
go with that feeling.
(laughs) Yeah.
Go with that feeling.
Trust your instincts.
It's so compelling.
I have an offer for you.
$250,000, but I want 40%.
Negotiate.
I'm wondering if there's
any other offers on the table.
I don't know, guys.
I love the product.
You guys are great.
Um, I-I hate to agree
with Kevin,
but I think the Valuation
and his numbers are about
where it needs to be today.
I mean, you could prove us wrong
in two or three years,
but today that's where
I would see it.
Even at $1 million in sales
by the end of this year?
Yeah, because, you know,
you're gonna make
about $150,000, $200,000
at the bottom line.
I'm giving you full value.
I'm out.
Okay.
It's fabulous to be
an oprah gift pick,
and I know how that
jump-starts your business.
I'm not convinced that doing
this at the valuation
that you've given would be
the right deal for me,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
Come to daddy.
We would love to be
partners with you.
We really want
to get closer
to the valuation.
Then do it.
We have grown this company.
We've not just grown product.
We've grown the brand.
With qvc,
we started with one airing.
Now They've asked us
to do five this year alone.
I believe you.
The only competitor you have
right now is you.
That's right.
It's a wide-open market.
My check is right here.
I'm willing to give you
$250,000.
I want 40%, because I'm
a disciplined investor,
and you want me
as a partner.
We do want you
as a partner,
and we do think that We'd make
a great team Together.
Then let's do it.
Are you willing to go closer?
No.
This is your moment
right now.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Kevin O'Leary is
Steven and Shane's last chance
for a deal.
You know, guys,
no bank is gonna touch you.
I am your bank,
and there's more where that came
from if you hit your metrics.
You need somebody like me
behind you
if you're gonna
grow this business.
So we are rock star creators
and visionaries,
and you're
a rock star businessman.
We'd like to know
if you'd meet us maybe halfway
between the 20% and 40%
and maybe do a 30% equity.
I rarely ever, ever change
my mind once I make an offer.
Practically never.
In fact, I can't remember
the last time I did,
because I'm
a disciplined investor.
But I'll do the deal at 35%,
'cause I really like you guys.
Mr. Wonderful,
you've got a deal.
You got a deal.
(daymond) Wow.
Congratulations, guys.
(Robert) Whoo!
(Lori) Good call.
I'm really excited.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
This is absolutely great.
I'm not kidding.
Thank you.
Let's go sell some tea.
All right. Absolutely.
All right. Let's do it.
All right. Take care.
Thanks.
(both) Thank you.
Thank you all very much.
(mark) Congratulations, guys.
(Lori) Yeah, congratulations.
Great job.
Y-you know what these guys are?
These guys are safe-crackers,
'cause they cracked that safe
around O'Leary's wallet...
(laughs) Wow.
'cause I've never seen him
open it before.
If there's one person
out there
who's gonna help us share
our teas with the world
and they're gonna help us
make a lot of money,
it's Kevin O'Leary.
I did not see that coming.
(chuckles)
I'm so excited. Wow.
Wow, was that great.
Next into the shark tank is
the Bradshaw family,
with a business created
by one of the girls
♪♪♪
Hi. My name is Maddie Bradshaw.
I'm 15 years old,
and I'm the President
of M3 girl Designs.
Hi. My name is Margot Bradshaw.
I'm 11, and I'm the V.P.
Hi. My name is Diane Bradshaw.
I'm their mom,
and we don't need
to disclose my age.
(sharks chuckle)
We're asking for $300,000
in exchange
for 15% of our company.
M3 girl designs,
a jewelry company
for girls ages 8 to 80,
started in 2006,
when I was just 10 years old.
The "M3" Stands
for Maddie, Margot, and mom.
It all started when I was
going into middle school
and wanted magnets
to decorate my locker,
but I couldn't find anything
that I liked,
and in my house, if we can't
find what we want, we make it.
So I made my own magnets out
of recycled bottle caps
from my Uncle's
old-fashioned Coke machine.
I drew up
some Really cool designs,
like peace signs, balloons,
and flowers.
I put them into the bottle caps,
and I attached a magnet
to the back.
My friends saw them,
loved them,
and started going crazy,
so I figured I came up
with a pretty awesome idea,
so I eventually created
snap caps--
the original interchangeable,
magnetic bottle cap Necklace.
Thanks, Margot.
Mm-Hmm.
Thank you.
Go, Mavs.
Go, mavs.
(Diane) go, Mavs.
That's what I like.
(laughs)
(bradshaws chuckle)
(Maddie)
So I took my snap caps
into a local toy store
in Dallas,
and I asked the owner
if she would start selling them.
Within two hours,
they had sold out
of all of our bottle caps
and necklaces,
and that's when my company,
M3 girl designs, was born.
I'm the vice president,
and that means
when the president goes down,
the vice president has
to step up.
(sharks laugh)
You know, Maddie's going
to college in a few years,
and I'll have all--I'll have
all of this to myself.
(mark and daymond laugh)
now that I'm 15 and Margot is
helping me with snap caps,
I decided that I wanted
a new jewelry LINE
geared toward my age group,
so my mom and I created
spark of life.
Spark of life is
adjustable necklaces
and stackable bracelets
for kids and adults of all ages.
Have you been selling these yet?
We've been selling
for about five years now,
and we're in
over 1,000 stores.
You're in 1,000 stores?
What? Whoa.
We're all over the Nation.
Yes.
And what are
your sales at now?
Well, over the past 5 years,
we've hit over $5 million.
(sharks) Whoa!
Dang. (chuckles)
That's not too shabby.
What were your sales last year?
Our sales last year were
about $1.6 million.
(laughing)
(chuckles)
and where were you selling?
What stores?
Uh, we sell to specialty stores,
So apparel stores, toy stores,
a lot
of large department stores.
What was your profit?
Our--
um, $1 million.
So, Maddie,
you're a millionaire.
I guess you could say that.
At 15. (chuckles)
Wow.
(chuckles)
Dang.
She's also an author.
Mm-hmm.
An author? What do you write?
Yes. Um, I wrote my own book
to inspire other kids
to start their own business.
Can I see the book?
Yeah.
How did you find
these 1,000 retailers?
Like, do you have
a distributor?
Well, we started off in just
a few local stores in Dallas,
but then, um,
we just were approached
by more and more stores,
and then we got a sales rep,
and now I think we have about
ten reps that sell our--
mm-hmm.
And where do you make them?
Do you make them all
in your house or--
they're all handmade
in our office in Dallas.
Your first line, you said,
was the bottle caps,
and that's what's
made for you
the $5 million in sales,
correct?
Yes.
Right.
And then you are now going on
with what you feel is
for an older, uh, girl...
yes.
A more mature girl.
We're a company.
We're not a one-hit wonder,
so for us, it's always about
introducing the next thing.
What are your margins?
Um, snap caps,
about 75 cents,
and, um, spark of life,
around $2.
Good Margins.
Who owns the business?
I mean, structurally.
Do you guys all own it
together?
Yes, we do.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
Including--the girls have
ownership equity in it?
Absolutely.
One question that
I think is important--
in this economy, jewelry has
been a very tough sell,
so how do you feel that
that has affected you
and your sales?
It's a $10 piece of jewelry.
(speaks indistinctly)
Is everything
at that price point--around $10?
The most expensive thing
is $10.
Hey, Maddie, why do you need
the money
if you made $1 million
last year?
You're asking for $350,000.
Am I missing something?
Um, well, we want it
for global distribution.
We're looking for a partnership
to take us to the next level.
So here's what I think.
For 300k...
I'd do a deal
for 30%.
Okay, I'm--I'm gonna
make you an offer.
Okay. (chuckles)
What I would like to do is,
I would like to go in
with Mr. Wonderful here...
ah.
And...
what?
Yep. I'm gonna go in
with Mr. Wonderful.
Are you okay, Lori?
I-I--yes, I'm having a moment.
I'd be happy to have
your partnership...
I'd like to go in
with Mr. Wonderful...
because of your talents
on television.
Except he needs to be
a silent partner,
and the silence starts now.
(laughs)
See how nasty she can be?
And what I'm going to do--
well, before you guys
decide anything--
Well, hang on. Let's hear
the offer from Mark.
(Kevin) Let's--Let's hear
the offer. Let's hear the--
okay.
Lot of noise over here.
We're gonna take 40%--I'm upping
a little bit--but I--
ouch!
Wait.
(mark) There's always a catch.
But the catch is, I am going
to personally mentor you
and help you get into qvc,
into retail stores globally.
I'll help take you everywhere,
because it is very difficult
to get into qvc,
and even more difficult
to stay on qvc.
And I hope that together,
you will have hundreds of
fabulous products you'll create.
So, Maddie, Maddie, there's
a lot of hot air up here...
(laughs)
But at the end of all
of that wonderful mentoring,
was she's making a worse offer
than Kevin.
(Kevin) Are you gonna
make an offer or what?
She wants 40% for $300,000.
Huge value.
Now think about this.
And I gave her my mentoring,
which is invaluable.
And my connections.
And I'm gonna get your cost down
by At least 30%.
I thought you were
the silent partner.
No, I'm gonna make some noise
about this.
(laughs)
I think we can make
these things for 30% less.
So our margins go up,
you make more money,
and then you get that Ferrari
before you get a license.
(Lori) I agree.
You know, you want to be her
one day.
There's no question about that.
(chuckles)
What do you say to that offer?
I wanna hear
What else is on the table.
Good answer.
Especially
from the Dallas man.
Of course.
And daymond, our fashion guy.
(chuckles)
Well, let me clear the field.
As painful as this may be
for me to say,
there may be
some other sharks here
that would be more beneficial
to you.
I'm out.
But thank you, though.
Margot, you guys haven't
heard from me yet...
(Diane) Yeah.
And that's intentional.
Um, I don't want
to do business with Kevin.
It doesn't matter what you want.
It's not your business.
But Lori has some very specific
advantages that she offers.
So why don't Lori and I
partner up?
But 40% is being
a little bit greedy.
I think we should
take the offer back to 30%.
(Lori) All right. Done.
I'll do the deal with Mark.
Sorry, Mr. Wonderful.
Ohh.
So the offer is that
Lori and I partner in together
for $300,000, the cash
that you asked for,
for 30% of the company.
That--that's our offer
that I hope you take.
But I wanna feel
that Maddie feels that this is
a wonderful opportunity
That's just come your way.
I'm looking for that enthusiasm,
that excitement.
But we haven't heard
from Robert, either.
Know what? I'd like to speak,
'cause I haven't finished...
well, hang on a second.
With my offer, 'cause you're not
in this thing right now.
So let's just--
no, no. Hang on. I am in
this thing for a second.
What do you want?
I don't think Maddie Wants
to give up 30%.
Correct.
Yes. Yes.
I'd like to say a few things.
Hang on a sec, Kevin.
Am I right or not?
(chanting) Shark fight.
Shark Fight. Shark fight.
What's your offer?
Yes. Yes.
That's the lack of enthusiasm.
(Lori) He hit it. Okay.
Now Let's--hold on.
And then we're wide-open
to a counteroffer.
I have not had a chance
to speak, and now I'm going to.
First of all, I wanna
remind you of something.
When you build a business
like the learning company
to $1 billion dollars
and sell it for $4.2 billion,
you learn a lot.
So I'm saying that I should own
a piece of this business
for what I know,
but I'm having trouble
with the valuation metrics here.
Because I'm also
a very wise financial investor
and I know what you're worth.
However, mark dropped it down
to 30% to stay competitive.
I would do that deal again.
I'd drop it down--
it's killing me to do it,
I have to be honest--
but I'd do it for 30%, not 40%.
And maybe, Robert,
just to keep things interesting,
if you really wanna
be part of this,
include you as well.
I'll come in on that offer.
Guys, with the exception
of daymond,
you have four people
very interested.
You pretty much get to write
your own ticket.
So why don't you tell us
who you'd like to work With.
Who do you wanna work with?
Um...
♪♪♪
Maddie Has two offers
on the table--
$300,000 for 30%
from mark and Lori,
and the same offer
from Kevin and Robert.
With Four sharks interested,
they wanna know
who Maddie wants to work With.
Who do you wanna work with?
Um...
I don't know. What do you think?
(whispering indistinctly)
What about me?
(Robert) Diane, there's
no secrets in the family!
You're not "the family" Yet.
(mark laughs)
(speaks indistinctly)
(Lori laughs) I'm not in yet.
I love that.
(mark) Margot's great.
It's a huddle.
(Margot speaks inaudibly)
No.
Okay. Never mind.
I'm good.
(whispers indistinctly)
Okay.
(speaks indistinctly)
Three sharks,
but...
we want Robert, Lori, and mark.
Big mistake.
And at what percentage?
20%.
20%?
Ooh.
(Maddie) Nothing more.
Nothing more?
Nothing more.
(Lori) Mm. I think 20%...
is Low.
(Robert) Maddie, I wanna stick
to the 30%.
(whispers indistinctly)
Okay. We will--
(speaks indistinctly)
tell me.
(all laugh)
Margot, that always happens
when you're the youngest.
(Lori laughs)
(speaks inaudibly)
Fine.
Okay, you have the offer
on the table.
(Lori) What are you thinking,
Maddie?
30%, but we want season tickets
for mavs games.
(Lori laughs) Good one!
Good one!
Margot, get a pair for me.
Ask for...
(laughs)
You can do it.
Come on, mark.
You own the team.
(laughs) Hey!
Please?
I'd give you season tickets,
but we're all sold out.
But any time you wanna come sit
in my suite and hang out
and bring the whole family,
bring friends, done.
So, mark, are you in?
$300,000, the 30%,
Robert, Lori, and I.
Yes. Yeah.
Deal?
Deal.
Deal. Done.
(Robert) Done. All right!
(laughs) Margot...
(speaks indistinctly)
god, I love...
Awesome! Nice job!
Yes, you, too.
I got screwed out of that one.
They ran you over, man.
Maddie, great job.
Thank you.
(all speaking at same time)
(Diane) Oh, thank you, guys.
See you guys soon.
(Diane and Maddie) Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, guys. Great job!
Amazing.
(exhales deeply)
(all laugh)
That 15-year-old kid got
$300,000 from mark, Lori, and I.
$300,000, tickets in a box,
and ran over you like
the flea-bitten scurvy dog
you are.
(laughs)
I'll getcha back, big boy.
I know you will.
Don't worry about that.
Well, at least you'll try.
Good job, man.
Good family, good people.
I can't believe that we got
to pick our own partners.
I never would've thought that
that would happen.
We--I thought we were gonna
be lucky enough
to get a deal from one shark,
and we got three with us,
so that's great.
I'm really excited.